[music]
so if politics is not
organized in a way that is close to the citizens and supported by the citizens,
then politics is wrong, there
is always a tension, but
you can resolve a tension
, you can do it productively
and that is why it is so important that we
start this conference honestly and do it
and a  conference convened in the
citizens should above all be
given the opportunity to
participate in the questions of how to proceed,
that means
it is very important to the european parliament from the beginning that
at the end of the conference a follow-up process
must start that consistently draws the
conclusions of the  conference translated into old
quasi acting we need a
europe that tries much harder in this direction in
partnership with
others to constructively solve the actually upcoming
global challenge
these features in your hands
[music]